allez c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
dans un match toujours montré miss
univers c'est pas la france
on a perdu ma loison c'est mexique ouais
je suis un peu pressé excusez moi parce
que ce soir il ya rambo iii tout le
monde
alors ici il ya des vraies questions
l'actualité est chargée en ce moment et
on se pose les vraies questions qui vont
révolutionner ce pays
tout de suite la question la grande
question du jour c'est la réouverture
des terrasses va-t-on pouvoir aller aux
toilettes est la grosse grosse question
je vous dis regardez bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie a évoqué le sujet
aujourd'hui sur ses news
et ouais alors pipi pas pipi nouveauté
chez vous sur twitter dans cette
émission n'a pas peur des sujets qui
fâchent comme anne-sophie lapix 1 est
elle trop méchante avec jean castex et
bien sûr sur le plateau nous avons des
éminences grises spécialistes qui
s'affrontent avec des termes très
scientifique qu'est ce que mais c'est
pas possible
quand et guti et la dose est sévère avec
vous montiez bravo à lui mais vous êtes
devenu un suspens le mans et particules
fait 30 ans que vous faites des états
vous suce boules avec tout le monde et
images pour dire suce boules je peux
dire qu'avec des experts comme ça c'est
dans l'air peut trembler vu comment
évoluent les missions mon cher cyril
j'ai peur qu'un jour les débats dans tpm
paix ça devienne comme ça moi j'aurais
parlé comme si aller l'ancien du racing
concentration si tu le prends comme ça
qui devait nous c'est moi aussi un jour
j'irai
[Rires]
l'état de la france je pense que des
ministres décide comme ça à part ça
cyril comme tous les lundis j'ai essayé
de résumer les meilleurs moments de la
semaine de tpm paix dans le multi des
complexes adore qui décomplexe pour
m'accompagner et stéphane bon sens n'est
pas bon sens philippe est aujourd'hui un
menu de ce multi des complète je cite un
policier d'extrême droite un gérant de
club échangiste une tique tox femme
d'eric zemmour on ne se régaler la dream
team
allez la 2e minute et déjà comprend très
intéressant pour ce policier d'extrême
droite il s'élance il ferait moi le
racisme dans la police ça n'existe pas
totalement décomplexé pleine lucarne
ouais c'est normal ils jouent chez les
bleus en même temps donc rien ne sais
pas qui de plus en principe les bleus
didier deschamps ou les blogs ce
monsieur ok on rappelle que tous les
bleus 1 de son équipe ne joue pas comme
lui heureusement des gestes du joueur
qui n'a pas donné le nom de quelques
stars coeur participer vous allez être
surpris cias en ce sens mais pas le
faire demain sur non c'est maintenant je
verrai myriam qui sera l'invité le 18
mai je m'en fous voulaient pas savoir
mais s'il ya eu céline dion france
gagnera pas mieux
[Rires]
la boulette et je ne dis pas ça parce
qu'il est tunisien oui c'est assez
violent mais vous avez vu bernard
montiel
ce joueur est expérimenté il reste sur
ses appuis oui absolument alors monty
est un joueur d'expérience et vaki kung
fu bosser et bronzés mais sur les
panneaux d'une petite rockeuse
totalement déjanté alors est-ce que bfm
tv a bien fait de diffuser le portrait
tu du présumé
voilà justement résumé jeudi à présumer
parce que le suspect nie toujours les
faits oui selon le procureur et du
moment qu'il ya des personnes qui ont vu
la scène je ne vois pas pourquoi on ne
pourrait pas le maître futures stars
incroyable incroyable c'est bien ce dont
20 le retenez pas parce que de toute
manière on va la revoir
elle dit exactement ce que les
populistes va l'entendre et elle vient
du sud c'est magnifique elle a une
bouillabaisse dans la tête on sent que
quand elle bouge au ya la soupe aux
choux oui mais vous savez c'est sa
jeunesse ça c'est la fougue de la
jeunesse en deux secondes
elle a réfléchi ça va très vite chez les
jeunes pop on l'a vu donc c'est lui
qu'on la rejoigne un genre de pression
tu l'as vu quoi tu es coupable
peut-être que si les parents avaient
créé du curé de leurs enfants le cerveau
ne se retrouverait pas sur bfm tv et toi
poulette si tu serais moi allez sur tik
tok tu serais mieux parler français elle
me rappelle mon fils c'est très mignon à
mais il est charmant votre fils en plus
cela il est grand maintenant quel âge il
absolument cinq ans ils parlent mieux
quelques semaines ou le pantalon
d'enfants à capter les deux écrans il ya
un être très décomplexée pour pas dire
trop décomplexés est ce qu'il ya autour
de la table qui est allé chez vous oui
c'est une banale a dorénavant c'est
comme ça devenait sur un plateau télé et
vous jetez doute vous dites il ya un
chroniqueur ici il a acheté deux kilos
de drogue mais je peux pas dire le nom
avait très très belle action l'a pas vu
arriver
d'ailleurs j'ai un jeu de mot avec
chroniqueur parce que produit n'est au
bout d'un moment j'entends une jeune
femme arrivée en criant hurlant et avec
son son homme qui me dit ah c'est intel
qui là c'est un tel quel c'est pas
possible
mais je peux plus je veux futé il a
vraiment il a vraiment il a vraiment de
que dallas
alors là la précision à 98 en 2021 pas
si le gérant de l'époque en passant maur
des fossés quel but
buts mais c'est ça qu'il faut faire un
moment donné c'était pas un il faut
aller direct dans l'action il faut pas
prendre de gants allait encore les
enfants écartez vous de l'écran line
hockey
oui je le vire est sûre le choquait pas
par le bas ouais d'accord le sida ok
mais le virus jusqu'à preuve du
contraire il va pas rentrer dans le but
non non là pour lui ont dit à dakar
justement il est très porté là dessus
ces tables tout appel à la exceptionnel
ce soir dans le regard de cyril hanouna
vous voyez quand il est là il dit à mes
parents qui regarde il ya des proches à
ma famille a des envies d'enfant soit là
bravo cyril vraiment c'était un moment
exceptionnel a vivement la semaine
prochaine pour les uns des evala
n'oubliez pas trop de blabla trop de
tracas
[Applaudissements]
ça